[Music]
i think that
freedom
everywhere anywhere
is
love
letting yourself be loved which is
always risky and loving
which is maybe even riskier
i've been a monk here at tuscan for 47
years
[Music]
[Music]
i suppose is the greatest freedom of all
because
it's a relationship
it's a gift of god
it's very
mysterious i think
it's a gift
and you just
accept what comes
silence is
an enabling
thing
it frees you
for
listening
for
availability for
avoiding imposing yourself
how often in speech are we trying to do
someone down or demonstrate our
superiority or all of that
so
silence frees you from those things
most monks
do all sorts of things
so you take your turn washing up peeling
the spuds cooking the lunch driving the
car
many little jobs
just like a family
[Music]
which means
what you possess
possesses you
the less you've got
the more freedom you have
and that's
a freedom which is quite hard to acquire
in some ways because letting go of
things is detachment is difficult but
it's essential for freedom
because
as our lives go on
you have to let go of things
maybe your memory maybe your sight maybe
your hearing maybe mobility
you got to let them go
because one day
you have to let go of your life
the ultimate
impoverishment
but that's the only way to get to the
freedom of eternal life
[Music]
[Music]
it will be tough at times everybody's
life is tough at times
but
as they say the retirement benefits are
out of this world
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video